welcome oh hi hello home how's it going
feeling good alright so uh let's get
into this a fantastic trailer this is a
different kind of Frankenstein story
than we've seen before so maybe let's
start with you Paul and talk about what
the relationship is between Victor and
Igor and and why the story is different
and the relationship between beta and
Igor is a we find the Igor the beginning
of the movie and he's all hunchback and
what you'd expect
ego to be but then you kind of see that
he's got this passion for anatomy in
science and all those good things and
then he meets up with Victor
Frankenstein who also sees that in him
and sits together the the work together
to build was a prototype and then it
becomes monster and all that stuff and
they're all about science is about this
passion that they have for and also it's
um it's a love story between these two
men really and yeah and I think that in
a very song positive beautiful thing and
then and did it yes a lot of Soviet in
these two guys who who need who need
each other and fight Victor needs gore
probably more than then ego needs needs
very bitter in his life and it's really
about creating it's actually a big
giving the name Frankenstein back to the
scientist a bite to Victor Frankenstein
yeah and because everyone always thinks
it's the monster and all that stuff so
it's that was great you know that was a
really good challenge to help him every
time somebody says to me what you do in
the morning say I'm doing this film
Frankenstein see who you playing I say
I'm playing Frankenstein you're like
you're kind of short did we play in the
monster and of it no it's the doctor so
yeah you're right we're giving the name
back to dr. Beck yeah but is there
people always get that wrong and girls
like freaks like monsters Frankenstein
by the way I just want to point out
you've probably the greatest hat I've
ever seen in my life which is it says
it's Frankie Goes to Hollywood but it's
Frankenstein's monster and
Frankenstein's monster sing relax
those are unseen before you thanks had
well we are delayed up Thank You doc
well um we have made up for the career
at the end those are endocrine end of
picture gift for the crew got a really
cool hat they might actually wear us
like cuz normally there's stuff you get
on tops you'd ever wear out you know was
this is actually quite a cool hat yeah
well so let's talk about the
relationship of Igor and picture because
I from what I'm to understand I haven't
seen the movie I mean they wouldn't show
to me I asked they said no you have to
wait but it seems like that Igor is more
of an intellectual equal to victor in
this story rather than just like a
grumbly sidekick yes I mean the at the
beginning the stories as Paul mentioned
Igor is kind of being kept and living in
objects sort of conditions where he's
treated almost as as being sort of
subhuman and then um Viktor finds me in
these conditions and sort of lift me out
of that and to me the the that sets up a
very interesting dynamic in their
relationship which is that my life has
essentially been saved and made possible
by this man and then as we embark on
this journey together and he starts
losing his goddamn mind I'm like trying
to like pull him back from the edge of
insanity and it's that thing how do you
how do you stand up to and and and tell
somebody they're wrong when they've when
they have given you everything and it's
it's the so the imbalance in that
relationship is and the tension the
results from that is kind of what makes
it interesting and and ultimately you're
behaving so badly yeah that I am I'm the
only person who sees you know you when
you are at your most charming
charismatic so I can I I'm the only one
who would have any desire to save you
yeah I mean I think the movies fueled by
the fact not just about creating the
monster and all that but also these two
guys are together who have such a good
time together and as an audience I think
you want them to be together
it's exciting to get any all these
adventures and all these escapes that's
half the time the other half the time is
movie but if you've ever wanted to see
Daniel Radcliffe utterly abused and
beaten up and Rogers lobster and
embarrassed and just manipulated yeah me
then that's your movie that's a lovely
movie so half the time the audience are
like ah these guys are great together
now other half the time the gun please
Daniel run away no we have something
outside somebody wish out this movie
somebody said to me outside this is
really violent movie right I was like no
not
ticularly no no but to you I was oh yeah
I guess yeah but yeah yeah I we had like
I get thrown around a lot but it's good
I bounce I mean when all right
tumblr just imploded uh when you first
when they first approached you about
potentially playing Igor are you like
are you what are you serious or no not
at all I was like okay cool
tell me more that sounds great um yeah I
mean and as soon as you know I read the
script it became apparent that this was
a very different Igor and somebody does
have a very rich intellectual life and
and is you know if not the the academic
equal effect that certainly has like
it's a very equal partnership in terms
of what they're creating and his sort of
I my skills kind of fill in the gaps of
his you know a lesser abilities um so
yeah I mean I thought there was no like
I know
well I supplement you um you do what to
me o darling guide oh I didn't even buy
him dinner but he was coming at me
I was like listen man you want to put it
there go for it but um no hands
yeah Tumblr's dead Tumblr's dead
hahahaha was dead and and a thousand
slash fix were born this I just pointed
out there's a sign here this is got our
names I says it says welcome to
comic-con please be aware that many
members of your audience may be under 18
years of age we didn't say anything my
out of line right anyway now that
forever for some actors that's a little
more of a warning like don't flirt you
know like it's a little more be careful
I know Kat says like a party but ask for
ID it's worth it I mean oh yeah
James how does does Victor see Igor as
is equal to see does he recognize that
in the story I think like Liam Neeson in
the film taken Victor recognizes that he
has a very particular set of skills
yeah and
and he decides that he can use them and
use him but in doing that and
manipulating them and totally abusing
him and taking advantage of him he
actually comes to love him and care for
him and love being with him and he's
excited by the prospect of somebody who
is in some ways is equal but his ego is
such and that his his passion and his
obsession which is the thing that we
share with Mary Shelley's original book
is obsession not just about monsters and
all that but obsession with scientific
advancement that eagle and that
obsession with advancing science and
doing something that he needs to do it
affects himself is really really sort of
gets it gets in the way of him loving
him and seeing him as his equal and
that's when he gets abusive every time
that he says no I don't think this is a
good idea you all but get your head
wrapped off that's like he's kind of
he's a kind of two sides of the same
coin you know and what is it that means
what is it that you think they're trying
to accomplish in this story together try
to build it big monster man don't you
try to build monsters and be a good
Christian I'm saying she's right just
gotta love America and uh build monsters
and [ __ ] yeah I mean I about man I
absolutely I got it
when uh what are we trying to do where
we tracked it what the thing I think in
money Shelley's original for me there
was something missing there is a that's
I know that's a Callistus eighty a lot
of people in all that concept it's an
amazing book a very important book but
for me Victor was obsessed and crazy
just because he was I didn't really see
a reason what is this story and what max
did and what you did and what we've done
together is give him a reason for being
somebody crazy and they're not cured of
him
cure him of that halfway through in the
book he kind of just like goes I'll go
for a vacation for eighteen months in
the woods and then I come back and I'm
Kelly um I'm sorry no we need to kill
the monster what is in this we keep him
mad all the way at the end and I think
that's true to his trauma and his
backstory and who yes any more fun cuz
mental people are fun
you mentioned max and I assume you're
referring to max landis
who wrote the who max is such a
brilliant mind for coming at a story
from an angle that you can edit and he
just he says it like you go I'm gonna go
to Starbucks I'll just be like what
about this you're like damn Yolanda
he's such he is such a brilliant mind
and it's such an interesting way of
storytelling is that was that what
attracted you and after direct
definitely I mean Mike's it was kind of
extraordinary isn't he's a little bit uh
you know he's just as extraordinary mine
work what he did is he basically he
cherry picked all the good ideas from
from the movie from the book itself and
he's created his own monster you know
within that so he's made he's made the
script which has Igor Anna which is of
course ego was never in the book and it
has has these other little monsters that
have never been in the film so you know
I mean so he's kind of a create see is
he's on my yankin Stein himself you know
uh he also is just like it's unashamedly
entertaining and blood boy yeah as well
it's like exciting it's never just
enough for it to be like I do you
watching these you got late the story's
always yeah there's like an energy
behind it which i think is is from him
like yeah yeah I mean there was never
one scene in this movie where I just
goes right I've got an easy day today
not you know it's just two guys talking
no way we did it anyway go every single
time we had a seeming for like how
physical and violent can we make this
another dangerous can we make each other
come on man yeah and we've quite similar
and like energy level in terms of
physical ability so we're just gonna go
out it with each other like every day
twelve hours a day and then we filmed no
kneepads ah you just feel like I feel
like he's doing it on purpose but I
don't know if he's doing it on purpose
that's that's that's yeah that's how it
is yeah I'm just I am a walking penis
joke I'm always ready to look at the
happy yeah but without there are some
there's what one scene we made take like
I mean subtly homoerotic the one where
you all like it the first scene we sure
I think we shot together which revolves
a lot of being thrown around oh you want
to act it out or you just want to talk
about it gopher yeah
uh-huh oh god this is this is the
enduring image that I'll take away from
the first day of the shoot right why do
we do
there was a low as a very nervous it up
a moment then about always joking he's
dokey he's not really honored we are
doing this okay we are we are we are
showing the the scene where he pressed
me up against I was wearing field
protection it was already there was one
there was one like that was a scene
where I like I came out of there cuz we
would like we wanted to make this film
like a dark movie and where's that and
it's dark and it's funny anybody's like
you know we didn't want we wanted it to
be like you know to push things and
there was definitely really first haha
that first moment I didn't do that one
Oh what we're just talking that first
moment when James like is like breaking
my back essentially and like trying to
remember there's no way of saying this
is all becoming innuendo I was about to
say removing my hump I mean I don't know
there's no we're getting out of this not
um so when we know whether I'd remain
listen whether you're building a monster
or making love it's all the same it
doesn't matter um I thought yeah but
that that was the first thing that I
remember like walking off set off that
and seeing like a couple of the
producers looking genuinely terrified
you